president Trump is expected to request
billions of dollars in new border wall
funding when he delivers his 2020 budget
proposal to Congress this morning the
president will ask for an additional
eight point six billion dollars to build
more than 700 miles of barriers along
the southern border he wants to cut
domestic programs to pay for the
construction it will renew his fight
with the Democratic congressional
leaders that led to record-breaking
partial government shutdown
earlier this year major Garrett is at
the White House major good morning good
morning lots and lots of numbers in the
federal budget and plenty of politics
the battle lines are already being drawn
not surprisingly over border wall
funding as we indicated the White House
once more and advisers here expect
congressional Democrats to start
negotiations on that topic at zero
meaning $0 and as this political
argument ensues we should note that
nowhere in this new budget does the
White House assert Mexico directly or
indirectly we'll pay for the wall so
much for that memorable campaign promise
Democrats are also likely to object to
this budget seeking more money for
defense spending while cutting
non-defense spending by five percent
this year and two percent in the
out-years they're also likely to object
to trillion-dollar deficits now and for
many years in the future no prospect of
balancing the federal budget for 15
years now as part of this budget debate
there will also be action in the Senate
this week on the president's national
emergency declaration there'll be a
resolution of disapproval likely to pass
even with Republican votes the White
House knows it will prevail on that
because the president will veto it the
first of his presidency will be
sustained in the house but that skirmish
biana
will foreshadow what is likely to be a
confrontation later this year we're
border wall funding that could bring us
what another shutdown scenario we are
allergic to those words major thank you
another fight for the washing for the
White House coming up